the postmodernist they're the they're
the logical conclusion of the
Nietzschean dilemma god is dead value
the value structure collapsed the
specter arises of all value structures
collapsing that's the post modernist
dogma all value structures have
collapsed they're only there for the
purposes of exclusion
they have no intrinsic value it's a very
very powerful argument that's why it
dominates the universities that and the
fact that allows people decision to
dispense with their moral responsibility
which is something that's never
discussed by the post modernists but you
have to give the devil his due
what's the problem with post-modernism
well if all values structures have
collapsed then there's nothing to do
because in order to do something one
thing has to be better than another
because otherwise why do it and so
people who are ensconced in the
postmodern traditions are undermined by
their own philosophy they can
deconstruct their own deconstruction in
which case they might as well just sit
there and do nothing which would
actually be preferable to what they're
doing now so how do they extract
themselves from that dilemma they do it
eeeh logically but they don't care
because the post modernist first of all
don't believe in logic that's a
reflection of the logos which they've
dispensed with dialog they don't believe
it because that's a reflection of the
logos which they've dispensed with logic
and dialogue are irrelevant well that
does bring up the problem of what to do
well as post modernists finessed that by
reverting to the Marxist doctrines from
which post-modernism emerged and so they
say well yeah you can't get any
direction from post-modernism but we
don't we're not going to worry about
that because we don't worry about such
things what we'll do is just use sleight
of hand to push forward the
communitarian doctrines out of which our
original hypothesis emerged and everyone
says well we'll turn a blind eye to the
paradox because we actually need
something to do
and plus to the degree that we're
communitarian we can take out our
nihilistic resentment and arrogance and
ingratitude on every single person we
deemed to have something more than we
have and so if you're wondering why
certain values can exist in the absence
of any value you have to look no farther
than to understand that people who are
desperate and chaotic will still be
angry and destructive and they can
manifest that perfectly with the moral
mask that says well I'm not really after
what you have because you have a little
more than me I'm speaking on behalf of
these people who have even led like it's
absolute nonsense it's so funny watching
Yale students complain about the
privileged they're in the top one tenth
of one hundredth of a percent of people
who've lived in in the entire history of
the planet much less just the people
that are on the planet now they're
dominating patriarchs in training right
there baby representatives of the
patriarchy and all they do is complain
about that tiny tiny infant essa mole
fraction of people who have slightly
more than they have now it's appalling
and their idiot professors pass them on
the back and send them off the world to
do that instead of teaching them how to
live they damage their mental health
they hurt our society they're bringing
things down and that's what they're
aiming at the post modernist managed to
be nihilistic and totalitarian at the
same time which is something that not
even Nietzsche dreamed about despite the
fact that he had the greatest
imagination for pathologies that perhaps
ever existed in addition they combined
the nihilism and the totalitarianism
with the worst aspects of dogmatic
religion because what they've
essentially established is a cult into
which children who attend University are
now indoctrinated at great cost I might
add and with very little practical
outcome